(upbeat piano music)
- If you've been here before,
you'll notice something
cropping up, time and time again.
Hot thermal waters powering
Hungary's age-old love of spas.
A love that can be traced
back thousands of years.
A history that can still be seen today.
Hungary has a unique geology
that allows deep thermal waters
heated by the Earth's mantle
to spring to the surface.
It's no surprise to hear, then,
that Hungarians have been
making use of this for thousands of years.
But how did this obsession begin?
Well, we might have to get dirty for this.
Let's start near the beginning.
Now, let's skip forward a few centuries.
And finally, to a time
that's more familiar.
(gentle piano music)